GENE GURKOFF: I started
running in marathons
to raise money for
Parkinson's research,
in honor of my grandfather.
I always had this idea that
if I could get enough people
together, then
collectively we would
have the clout of a
celebrity, and then companies
would want to sponsor us.
Being on the Android platform
has enabled us to reach people
all over the world.
They can help raise money
for our charity partners,
and it's helped make our
movement a global one.
IAN HAWKINS: It's really
cool to take your hobby
and put it into
your full-time job.
Torque is an Android
app that allows
you to see all the
sensors on your vehicle
and to look at fault codes.
From the way it's happened
in the Google Play Store,
I've touched over a million
people with the app.
The community's dragged
me along with it
and told me what they want.
I've done that for them.
I'm very grateful
for where I am now,
and it's staggering
to see that something
I've written from
my garden shed is
liked by that many
people across the planet.
VICTORIA TROFIMOVA: We started
right after university.
It was myself, my
husband, and his brother.
Making games was
our childhood dream,
and this is what
we wanted to do.
Since we released "Cooking
Fever" on Android,
it totally clicked.
We realized that this
is the way to go,
and this is the
platform of the future.
We had millions of downloads
in the first moments.
When we started, it
was just three of us.
And now we're a company
of over 100 people,
making games that we
decide we want to make.
This has been a very
successful dream.